- Are those piranhas?
- What the (bleep)?
Are there like piranha?
(Asian folk music)
- [Man in Grey Shirt] Killer Karaoke,
feel like that's not a euphemism.
- They just threw in piranhas.
She's terrified! (laughs)
- This is gonna go badly for you.
- OK, it's frogs.
It's just frogs.
- I'm on the edge of my seat.
- (bleep)! Snakes?
- Oh my, what? Is that an alligator?
- She's like doing the
splits to stay out of it,
so she's showing off her vagina basically.
- Dude whatever you do,
don't get an erection.
She'll be able to feel it.
- It's just her sharing
a suit with a dude...
Oh wait.
- And now he just
squirted her with (bleep)
hot sauce or something.
- I don't know the waiver
system in Thailand,
but it's probably (bleep) up.
- What the hell is that?
That looks like (bleep).
What the?
- What is that?
What is that?
- That's a straight up dinosaur turd
that he just stuffed her face in.
And she doesn't look happy. (laughing)
- [Man in Grey Shirt] Classroom genius.
- It's kind of like they're
using these game shows
as a substitute for daycare.
- This is science for kids.
It's like teaching kids how
to do scientific (bleep).
- Bicycles into a mosquito.
- How do you transform a banana tree
into a microwave? (laughs)
- Whoever thought of these transformations
was absolutely high.
- This is like some MENSA level challenges
they're putting these kids through.
And they're nailing it.
- Why do the buckets
have holes in the bottom?
These kids are pretty smart.
I mean, I don't think
I'd be able to do this
when I was a kid.
- I feel like this is
like a training program
where Thailand selects its
top spies for the future.
- Now they're pretty much crushing kids.
- I feel like kids
shouldn't be at game shows.
They should be drawing crayons.
- Now they're making the fat kid
pull everybody in a boat
to further accelerate
his future back problems.
- Tears of success.
- I get this weird sense that
they're gonna be punished if they don't
do well in this competition.
This chick is crying.
Oh my God, just as I say that,
this chick is crying.
- I don't think you can get
American kids to do this.
- [Woman with Black Hair] Sunshine Day.
Well this looks happier.
Oh, no it doesn't.
- How do they come up with these ideas?
Like, what?
- I officially love this.
- This kind of reminds me of
the Nickelodeon game shows.
- Speaks to a level of
bravery of the Thai people
that they're able to do this.
I would probably (bleep) myself.
- They always wear pink too.
Is that like a Thailand thing?
Like guys wear pink?
I look just like her.
- She's singing just fine.
Why are you dunking her into the water?
(screaming)